entrei nessa de querer sair
viver com quem é certo contar com quem
está perto
brincar de divertir sair essa de querer
entrar passeio estava todo vermelho
contrariando o bom conselho fui
precisava te encantar e mons
veja logo meu pescoço chegue cedo pro
almoço quito negra quer casar vem vem
vem vem traz amanhã tinha feira
boto amor nessa fogueira que jantar pode
esperar a moça veja logo meu pescoço
chegue cedo para um almoço que torneira
quer cavar vem vem vem vem traz amanhã a
tia feira faltou amor nessa fogueira que
jantar pode esperar
entrei nessa de querer sair
viver com quem é certo contar com quem
está perto
brincar de divertir sair dessa de querer
entrar assim eu tava tudo vermelho
contrariando o bom conselho foi pro
samba de encantar e mons
veja logo meu pescoço chegue cedo pro
almoço que tom negro quer casar vem vem
vem vem traz amanhã tinha feira voto
amor nessa fogueira que jantar pode
esperar
os beija logo meu pescoço
chegue cedo por um russo que tu negra
quer cavar vem vem vem vem traz amanhã
tinha feira
boto amor nessa fogueira que jantar pode
esperar
ah o amor
[Música]
[Aplausos]